le vendredi 28 juin à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir basile de gagny c'est
lamine sissoko pour leur film meltem
basit soko est un trappistes qui a
commencé un petit peu sa carrière dans
le cinéma dans la vidéo par les ateliers
etc la ville de trappes
maintenant il est dans un long métrage
son premier long métrage il avait déjà
tourné un court-métrage avec basile
d'organismes et ils se sont retrouvés
pour ce long métrage donc meltem c'est
l'histoire de trois jeunes français qui
partent en vacances on était sur une île
grecque et leurs vacances sont un petit
peu bouleversée par la rencontre avec un
réfugié syrien dans cette île grecque
on suit leur histoire
à tous les trois à tous les cartes
maintenant avec avec se réfugier et donc
on aura la chance d'avoir les trois
acteurs principaux et le réalisateur qui
viendront nous parler de ce film ça sera
vendredi 28 juin à 20h45 procinema le
grenier à sel pour trouver tout ça sur
sylvain grenier à sel points comme deux
ans est pour toi
c'est ce repos mais sans racines là je
sais même pas où tu vas tu es là tu
crois que tu va sauver le monde
[Applaudissements]
correia
[Musique]
non